yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing any muscle oh yeah this is
actually the guy then I play the draw
against earlier when my does came this
is something really really questionable
opening white anyway we kind of used to
that I think by now anyway that there
was a guy a plane to draw against and I
forgot to press the record button that
was really a shame because it was a very
very sharp interesting game so here I am
white white is terrible on the dark
squares absolutely terrible but my
position is still somewhat weakened so
not see how this unfolds and I don't
know a theory at all this is probably
not helpful hmm yeah how do you play
against those do with the like five or
something and I wonder if I should
actually should have tried like a bishop
age six or so he grabs that Wow then I
wouldn't have thought that wouldn't even
have vaguely crossed my mind to take
that pawn right okay
so the chick here and then take the
phone it's a real real mess
hmm he might he might cancel long or
something I check him as always 93 you
can also just cancel I'm not sure I'm
canceling him I probably will give up
the second bishop
I mean I'm threatening Knight takes d4
and if yeah so that was to be expected
so Queen b6 I was thinking putting more
pressure on the pawn I also have c5 yeah
that's also pretty pretty logical
opening up and immediately getting rid
of the de-spawn information if he takes
on c5 Bishop b2 92 I'm not sure that I
want to win the exchange and I was
thinking I wanted to do this anyway
okay Knight bTW too was pretty moving I
guess okay now I can think of taking
this one yeah I mean I think I'll take
it mostly to have a person
so let's see rook c8 c4 by the way this
guy is extremely high rated but I've got
a 90% score against him it's a bit of a
weird thing okay so I'm fighting against
this Knight
I have no pawn structure anymore
but the bishop pal something that you
have quite often now you've managed to
get the the bishop habit you have to
make some kind of compromise with the
pawn structure yeah here I was thinking
I was intending rook b8
good night g5 huh it's a little bit like
takes takes Knight g5 is a bit of an
annoyance I wonder if I should go age 6
simply let's turn so that I can move the
Queen like to see some ruby 8 before
this would be the things crossing my
mind I wonder if he has some kind of
life available to put a knight on d6 no
it's probably useful move okay now I
play rugby ain't ideas also route B form
it would be nice to get in break this
control down no it just puts this ie one
single night at 5 I see him I see
[Music]
so attacking a to regime which it covers
so a night is 796 I came okay let's get
out of chicks
it's not not quite clear to me what's
going on here
to bishops against tonight's is very
nice but it's still a fairly fairly
messy kind of position I was even
thinking f5 but night-night to age force
knowing their don't know time warning
yeah would be five or something
I have Cooney three yeah he might just
take it I mean yeah he just takes it
hmm
ideas couldn't be worn or something it's
okay now I can take this he probably has
some fantastic tactic in line like a
knight f6 or something for Luke h5 so I
don't know I'm just taking this pawn and
then see what happens no fantasy no
tactic that's good taking you for him
cannot move the d5 Knight currently
because of rook to d1 yam this is Jack I
cannot take them mm-hmm I wanted to take
it doesn't work okay then it was a
stupid check then I wanted to take on d5
okay I know it's a blundering of seven
oh [ __ ] check check check check check me
Wow Hey [ __ ] that was close
oh my god
that was close okay so let's have a look
at this and see
so let's see I really have to look at
this opening hour
I mean it has the reputation of being
really rotten for white so I definitely
did not did not do well there c3 Adam
known what to do him Queen to b6 what
the engine is suggesting the nineties h4
is a shocking move really I think anyway
yeah so this this and Knight takes yeah
I've thought about that but I didn't
quite could make it work I think he can
I thought he can take you know I saw
this line but what I did not see is I
can take and after this I'm winning the
rook in the corner so that was already
winning for black this is my knight xh4
was for suppose was bad I saw that which
I didn't see yeah I saw this and then I
hear end it I just ended my my line
there and I can take here and I'm just
just probably a lot better winning is
strong word it's it's very close so that
that could have been could have been end
of the game and I'm losing I'm losing
the threat here somehow black is still
in in good shape of course rook could be
eight yeah maybe this is better and jam
I rejected this is this right off the
bat to win the exchange because of my
open king with me okay the engine is of
course fearless but but maybe I should
have done it now objectively speaking it
shouldn't work for white but it's a
blitz game and I know how bad I am at
defending those crappy positions yeah
here maybe the Queen trade here was bet
I am
this is something that that I also
after the game or not after the game a
couple of minutes later because I am in
this danger of having a bad bad King OKC
for was good if this is all about we're
being very precise with with calculation
and there wasn't yeah he won this would
be eight is still good check yeah I
wanted to take your father actually can
do it okay I was thinking it isn't
possible check but okay wookie a there's
nothing special there
she takes takes takes I still have the
ape horn okay no no we just got a messy
position yeah it was a bit of a panic
move I don't know
King g8 is just holding everything
comfortably job at the end of time
scramble thanks for watching